et on s'intéresse aux mystères de notre
mémoire et de notre intestin avec une
étude menée par l'inra et val de loire
et publiée dans la revue internationale
psycho neuro andy chrono endocrinologie
l'étude menée par l'institut national de
recherche pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et l'environnement sur
des cayes prouve que le stress profite
modifie le microbiote intestinal qui à
son tour perturbe la mémoire samuel
colin
lui peau dont un seul avec un vers de
farine son repas favori pour la caille
il s'agit de le retrouver les cayes
témoins vont pour beaucoup plus vite à
se pourrait qu'on pense qu'ils étaient
récompensés alors que les cailles
stressé mais plus de temps elles vont
faire aussi beaucoup plus d'erreurs pour
retrouver ce pourvoi et dans d'autres
peaux une démonstration rendue possible
grâce à ces isolateurs de l'inra val de
loire utilisé par exemple en
infectiologie dans l'étude elles sont 36
caille japonaise oiseaux bien connu des
chercheurs la moitié d'entre elles
reçoivent à la naissance un microbiote
altérée cet ensemble de bactérie
provient du système digestif d'une autre
caille préalablement stressé conséquence
directe même sens nouveau stress les
poussins grandissent avec des capacités
cognitives altérer le microbiote à lui
seul en tout cas c'est certain et
capable d'engendrer les perturbations de
mémoire et d'autres perturbations au
niveau cérébral par exemple qu'ils sont
cons observe dans le cas d'un état de
stress modéré croque le stress perturbe
le microbiote puis dans un second temps
la mémoire
si la raison de ce lien n'est pas encore
expliqué ces recherches pourrait servir
dans le domaine de l'élevage et pourquoi
pas à terme sur l'être humain